-Guys, today is Friday
and that's usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course, I send out
thank-you notes.
And I was just running
a bit behind today. I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now.
Is that okay with you guys?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Appreciate that.
Thank you.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-Last week, he was smiling
from ear to ear.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, spring allergies,
for basically saying,
"You can have nice weather
or you can breathe,
but you can't have both."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, behave.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Easter,
for being
the second-best holiday
where a magical person breaks
in to your house.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's the second-best holiday
where a stranger --
a magical someone breaks in.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Easter Bunny,
for always dressing
like a blackjack dealer
at Chuck E. Cheese.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-22.
-Good luck.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, New York City's
steam pipes,
for looks like Sixth Avenue
is celebrating 4/20 early.
[ Laughter and applause ]
My corner is vaping.
♪♪
Thank you, filing taxes
as a single person,
for being that time of year
you tell the government
you biffed it
on the dating apps.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Tried.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, napkin dispensers,
for always giving me
two options --
one napkin or 600.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'll take a pile.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
putting pennies
in a mall fountain,
because, if there's anywhere
my wish will come true,
it's between Hot Topic
and Cinnabon.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, quiche,
or as I like to call you,
egg pie.
There you have it, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Those are our "Thank You Notes."